معادات الساميه تهمه جاهزه لمن ينتقد
سياسات اسرائيل التمييزي تجاه
الفلسطينيين لكن الفلسطينيين يعتبرون هذه
الارض وطنهم التاريخي من النهر الى البحر
فالغرب يفسر هذه العباره بمحو
اسرائيل انكار وجودها او حقها في الوجود
فويل لمن يتلفظ بهذه العباره من المي
للميه الكونغرس الامريكي وبخ النائب رشيده
طليب لانها استخدمتها مره وطبعا هو قرار
اقل من الطرد ما قبل الطرد البرلماني
البريطاني وعضو حزب العمال اندي
ماكدونالدز تم تعليق عضويته بعد تصريحات
له عن تحقيق العداله بين النهر والبحر في
فلسطين المهاجم الهولندي من اصول مغربيه
ولاعب نادي ماينز الالماني انور الغازي تم
فسخ عقده بسبب كتابته عباره فلسطين ستتحرر
من النهر الى البحر
طيب ماذا لو استخدمت هذه العباره بشكل
معاكس من الطرف الاخر هل هذا يعتبر انكارا
لحق الفلسطينيين بالوجود او انكارا لحقهم
في الحياه على ارضهم التاريخيه هذا يائير
نتنياهو يكتب على انستغرام من النهر الى
البحر هذا العلم هو ما سترونه ماذا تفهمون
من هذه العباره طبعا يضع علامه اسرائيل هل
هناك حق للفلسطيني بالوجود على تلك الارض
تعالوا لنرى راي المتحدث باسم مجلس الامن
القومي الامريكي جون كيربي ما رايه بعباره
ابن نتنياهو عندما سئل
عنها not for the prime minister and med
account i think you can understand would
do look talked about thate has
a
اذا لا يود التعليق بالنيابه عن ابن
نتنياهو لا يريد باختصار ادانه نفس
العباره على لسان نتنياهو كما يدينها على
لسان الفلسطينيين رشا تقول من النهر الى
البحر لم تكن يوما معاديه للساميه مطالب
بحق الفلسطينين في ارضه فقط
دانيل لماذا حين خرجت المظاهرات تقول
فلسطين من النهر الى البحر غضب
الاسرائيليون اليس من حق الفلسطينيين ان
يغضبوا الان ديانا قالت ديانا فكره ان يحق
للاسرائيليين زوال فلسطين ولا يحق لفلسطين
ان تطالب بحقها في قيام دولتها فكره مزعجه
وتنوم عن نفاق كبير ادين العبارتين بشكل
متساوي او اصمتوا
جرمايا جرمايا تقول ابن نتنياهو يقول ما
يريد ولا احد يتهمه بمعاداته الساميه
لماذا هذه
الازدواجيه انه يريد زوال فلسطين بهذه
الفكره التي نشرها في ستينات القرن الماضي
استخدمت منظمه التحرير الفلسطينيه شعار
كدعوه للعوده الى الحدود الخاض على
السيطره البريطانيه على فلسطين بسكانها
العرب واليهود قبل وجود اسرائيل لكن
برنامج حزب الليكود اليميني الاسرائيلي
والذي صدر عام
77 يقول ينص على ان بين البحر والاردن لن
تكون هناك سوى السياده الاسرائيليه هذه هي
العباره الموجوده في دستورهم